Je le répète, la hausse des prix du gaz en Europe est devenue
le résultat d'une pénurie d'électricité et non
vice versa
et
pas besoin de traduire ce qui s'appelle de
tête malade à une tête saine comme la nôtre
dire et comment certains essaient de faire
Nos partenaires
toutes les dernières décennies pas à pas
L'énergie européenne a été posée
défauts systémiques, ce sont eux qui ont conduit à
crise de marché à grande échelle en Europe
signifie un environnement de prix élevés dans
peut éventuellement se transformer en négatif
conséquences pour tout le monde, y compris
fabricants pour tout pour tout
la stabilité du marché est importante et
prévisibilité
La Russie s'acquitte pleinement de ses
obligations contractuelles envers nos
partenaires, y compris en Europe
fournit garanti
des approvisionnements en gaz ininterrompus sur ce
direction, il y a toutes les conditions préalables pour
qu'à la fin de l'année nous atteindrons un record
volumes d'approvisionnement en gaz du marché mondial
de plus, nous avançons toujours
nos partenaires sont prêts à discuter
actions supplémentaires